welcome back folks hopefully people find
the stream
again this outage B brought to you by
Xfinity be sure to pay for one uh be
sure to pay for a gigabit line in order
to have daily
I think this is running did we remember
to do this correctly
though nope we got to switch this line
and let's see if this this still
works this should solve the bug I think
that what just happened it's not that
bad so what happened is that we were
like the XP range was too small so it
was potential that you were killing
something out where nobody is in XP
range yeah and if you kill something
when nothing is an XP range then there's
a dub VI by zero so it just
crashes greetings from
Germany currently on my Master's thesis
in safe RL and recently discovered your
channel enjoying your streams thank
you hope you find some stuff
interesting invalid X
P
possible oh I'm dumb yeah I'm
dumb um
function it should be
Max oops right here so the issue was uh
I think players use l players use l
Infinity for their attack range and this
was using L1 so it's like Square versus
Diamond you cut off the
[Music]
corners uh I think that this should work
now we'll see I'll be very surprised it
it's possible that there's something
drank going
on but hopefully not we'll see if we get
any errors
good this is running correctly now is it
running slower than
before nope not
noticeably we'll obviously have to read
do a little bit of
optimization
um it's very likely I have a line or two
that's not running and
see but it's pretty good so far so let's
see if we can extract any information
out of this um level tank
is okay tank is still even so far let's
see if it falls behind still
behind it's like good for a few levels
is the weird thing and then it starts to
fall behind which I assume means that
it's just not scaling as well as the
other
it
q and
W does it still have Mana problems or
something
it has what should be a very strong
ability it should be very very
let's wake up a little
here
so let me really think about the scaling
of this
if I'm saying that this is scaling
two points per
level then it's scaling it's five ticks
per second so it's scaling 10 DPS per
level is that
one 25 damage per second
right they
have no it's way more than 25 damage per
second what am I talking about it's 125
damage per second so ttk has like 4
seconds that seems like ridiculously
good already
it seems like they should get like life
steal
right it seems like they should get life
I think the thing that is difficult to
balance here
is to make this ability keep up with
where it is now this is like a 4se
second
ttk which is just like a stupidly strong
ability for a tank
character it doesn't need more damage
like it needs more sustain
right but it's already taking a lot of
damage it's already doing its job like
tanking all the damage
right let's actually I'm run this one
more
time because I want to get the
screenshot of the mid
game and get the screenshot of the mid
game actually you know what I can
do I want to track this one because I'm
actually going to use the WB graphs and
we're going to do something
cool going to do something
cool I'm trying to think of like what
tank characters
do they have abilities that help them
like stay alive usually something to
draw aggro so you have to hit the
freaking tank like annoying thing that
if you don't deal with the tank they're
like really obnoxious they don't just
kill you
damage it's
is it dealing enough
damage what we're going to do is let's
go get the graphs prepared in w b for
what I want to do and by the time we
prepare the graphs this will be like
this will be set up nicely I think
oh you can just do
level
assassin
where' your stupid plot go I made the
plot and nothing happened
it just doesn't make it okay I'll make
it manually stupid thing
okay it still didn't make it where's the
freaking
graph oh am I just dumb did I
like yeah I totally messed
up okay whatever
um here so this goes here
long long range carry
outside of XP
range I don't have attack ranges that
far for that to be a problem yet it was
just a damage formula uh
issue so here's the game at the moment
the tank is
not hold on let's add a
panel let's do this
dealt and then we'll do damage
received YouTube didn't send my
message if it had a link then it might
have Auto modded it other than that I
don't know it may be something
weird if you don't see it on the screen
here I'm probably not seeing
it okay so here we have some metrics
right the ignore these two I made the
graphs too many times by mistake
um so here we see that there's a level
Gap like
these at Mid
game you have level 17 to 18 carry
assassin actually mid game should be
considered
earlier so tank is two levels behind by
level 10 and support is three levels
behind and if we look at all the graphs
damage
received the tank is tanking damage it
has the highest damage received by
far it is actually aead in damage delt
as
well do you see that damage delt is like
at the
kills well I guess it doesn't have any
burst damage right
so it makes sense but then it shouldn't
be behind in levels it should be getting
the XP from Team
fights so actually the tank looks very
good here in the sense that it's like
very high damage dealt very high damage
received very low hero kills that's what
we want the thing I don't understand is
why it's behind in levels
job this is like the end of a game right
here
you can see that the carry eventually
like the other classes catch up with
damage dealt but then Heroes
underleveled why is he
underleveled why is he underleveled let
me
think go back to the XP
though how about
deaths it's low on deaths it should be
fine it's in the fight maybe it works
now initialize in range with
true and numb in range with one for the
player that's killed yeah so the thing
that you just suggested would
technically be safer yes so I will fix
that for now it's not ever doing this
but yes that is the way that you would
fix that I don't like this whole section
of code in general I want to figure out
a way to condense
it but it should be correct
what's the reason for using L1 over L2
Norm it's just less
math no real
reason it might be a little faster it
might not
be I don't know if it
matters this thing does you have to
remember this runs at over a million
frames per second
so little things like that can end up
mattering like having to do a square
root ABS is a really fast function to
compute right
you could use l Infinity if you wanted
as
well breakout runs at 1.1 mil SPS on GP
well done Noah very well
done very well done
indeed you can run a carb sweep for
hyper prams if you
want um you should
literally if you want to do 100 million
step runs like you could literally do
um you could do like the whole t run in
an
hour M after swimming
class 100 Mil is
planned
sweep I still don't know why this tank
is behind on
levels like it looks balanced otherwise
it's just like
you can see it's consistently behind by
a few levels
here like several
so yeah no it has low
deaths it's doing exactly what it should
be doing but for some reason it's not
getting
levels I mean I guess it's just because
like there's
no maybe it's okay right
like the other stats are balanced and
they're not playing as a team at the
moment so yeah technically if you're
just running it down mid right like the
tank isn't going to be able to secure as
many kills CU it has like this damage
overtime effect doesn't have like the
tanking and it's actually doing a ton of
damage as well in
AOE so I think the only one that we have
to deal with is the uh the support right
reasonable but the support's even lower
level than the tank isn't
it well let's take a look at the damage
numbers maybe and the hero kills
these numbers are honestly fine I just
don't think it's having the game impact
that it should have
because let me
see let's look at ability usage and
stuff
yeah so it's not
healing its team
enough it is using all of its abilities
though which is
good let's go look at the abilities
again Hook is probably fine
down we'll increase we'll decrease the
Mana
cost this is already pretty strong
so I think just decreasing Mana cost a
little than decreasing
this the
stun it already uses the stun fairly
often 3 seconds
stun it's already quite
strong I guess it's just it really needs
to be doing much more healing
right but it already has a huge AO
whoops okay five is already a very
strong AOE I
it's just not as strong because the
support is so far behind I
we also have to add up like all the
different heels right because like the
everybody I think that this might be
enough
here this might actually be balanced
enough for us to like play with the game
a little bit and start on uh like making
it actually more interpretable I think
this might be like a good first round
balance that we
have we'll see
we'll make proper graphs for all this
stuff as
dealt
delt okay these are good
so this should give us a nice balance of
everything and we'll get this as a cool
screenshot uh as soon as we get like a
full
game they're only at level
nine and then we will go off of
this as long as this is like reasonable
as expected
yeah look you can see the healing dealt
here is higher now with the support
we'll see if it continues scaling or if
the tank just massively
outscales but
um there's
level support and tanker are still
behind a fair
bit they're more team dependent though
so I guess it makes
this is way
better yeah yeah this is way better
so the support is
now it's still doing it's doing a lot of
self healing so it ends up tanking quite
a bit
ironically nowhere near as much as the
actual
tank but it is also doing more healing
to his allies which is good
any dead
skills this is a tech skill we don't
care if they're not using it and that's
the only dead
skill this is pretty
good five minute
meta look at the level distribution it's
pretty decent I still think that the
tank and supporter a little too far
behind they're like four levels behind
instead of two but um
the thing is
like I think that they're just more team
dependent
right like if you're if your damage
characters are just running it down mid
and not waiting for you and stuff then
yeah they're going to kill a bunch of
minions and then die and then if you run
it down mid like you're not going to
kill as many minions before you die
right so like if they were actually
playing better as a team I think that
this would be more reasonable but like
overall I'm happy with this because you
can see that tank starts out doing the
most damage right and then but it
doesn't scale as well its damage so like
the carry and the Assassin characters uh
end up doing better than it um how's
burst
here burst is up there with assassin
it's like just an allaround good
character I
think um assassin is like yoloing it so
yeah it has a ton of deaths support and
tank generally more reserved healing
dealt tank has most healing it's just
pure selfhealing so it's
sustain support comes in uh somewhat
close second split across the
team damage received the tank
tanks support tanks a little bit the
rest of them are way
lower I think everything is good here
these stats are all
good and if I'm looking at the skill
distribution like
I'm kind of I'm kind of amused that the
burst doesn't use its
W I think we're going to buff the burst
w a little bit and then we're going to
be
done CU it should be using its
AOE I think if I if I just make it
cheaper this might make it way too
strong we'll
see we're just going to Nerf the we're
just going to make it cheaper cuz it
should be using this it's a good ability
it must just be too expensive and we
don't care if the carry isn't using it
to que with that's a teack
skill we might have to play with it a
little bit because it just might be
awkward
yeah all right next five minute meta
I'll going use the restroom I'll be
right
back and uh yeah then after that we'll
probably start actually like playing the
game a little making it look better uh
putting new assets and you know actually
doing all that stuff so that should be
cool and we'll be able bble to use the
train policy to play against which will
be fun be right
doing oh look at that the burst um it's
a little bit
better does this give us a slightly
better
curve burst
yeah I think that was a good
buff still below the carry for damage
but it's pretty good and I I think it
probably scales
earlier thank you for the reminder linky
all this stuff is free and open
source right here so if you want to
whoops Let me refresh the
stream if you want to support my work
for
free you can do that by just checking it
out on
GitHub and starring the
let's check this last run and then let's
do uh some fun
okay so this is good this gives
the look at this so assassin is very
good
early and then burst in the middle
right and then eventually the late game
carry takes over so this is a perfect
curve
and then of course the support and the
Assassin are farther behind than they
should be because there's no team
play Hero
kills again
assassin then burst takes
over and then carry takes over which is
perfect death we're good damage
dealt a
tank it damage delt will be a little
different healing looks good
perfect we've done a solid job
here assassin burst
carry that's like a perfect curve
this
oops The Kills one works as well right
assassin why can't I see
this wait this is It's assassin
First Carry
right
yeah so let's just do
solid okay so we have this pushed now
and we can build locally
on the right
box here we go
so I don't want to get
um I don't want to get too bent up like
making a giant client but we need to add
at least some level of stuff to this
client I'm trying to think like what the
really
projectiles
okay brain is not working I might have
to go make a
coffee so I'm thinking like I'm just
trying to think like how can I Jazz up
the game in a way that I can make it
substantially better just
today simul all the parameters needed to
simulate no I just I just want to do I
just want to like improve the visuals a
little bit so that like you can tell
what's going on a little better right
that's all I'm thinking
um technically the best thing would be
to have like projectiles and stuff and
render projectiles but we don't actually
have projectile travel time in this so I
could just make like
a I could just make like an attack
animation or
whatever I could just make like an
attack animation or an attack
State like I have like the puffer that
puffs up or
whatever so I could make that the attack
Spate wait can you target a
space and Implement a time delay no
I mean I would have to change quite a
bit if I wanted a time
delay it like it would add non-trivial
logic I could do it it's just like I
don't know if it's worth doing
that like I I want to do the simple
thing first right like I want to do the
simple thing and see if it's like it
feels good enough to play and such um I
was was thinking I make an attack State
animation so like when you do
something there's like an attack state
which will probably just be the puffer
puffing up because I have
um I could make like a I could like tint
the enemies like I could do like a
damage taken effect
that would really
help I mean like
healing
stun
slow I could do all of these as
overheads
maybe
no I could do stun and slow as overhead
icons are you still writing and and
Publishing
papers um considering how garbage the
conference cycle has gotten lately no I
do still write technical manuscripts and
blog post type things but uh publishing
has essentially become a waste of time
that said there is a puffer 1.0 white
paper and it is possible that I have uh
it was possible that at least something
will be published in nerps this cycle
but like the review quality has just
gone to complete garbage like we have
like multiple papers that like provably
are using llms to just write all the
reviews and like yeah it's a mess
academia's become like a mess with
llms no interest to going back to
Academia none at all
whatsoever that doesn't mean now I'm
doing something that's pretty close to
that in in research right but like I
mean I basically now I'm just focused on
like how do I make RL good by whatever
means I feel like and I'm releasing all
the tools and I'm doing it kind of all
in the open but I'm no longer
constrained to like you can only work on
things that Academia thinks are
reasonable to work
on yeah I've gotten so much more done
frankly since graduating it's like it's
kind of ridiculous how much faster I've
been able to get stuff done
I do collaborate with academic Labs
though puffer provides uh free support
to a couple different academic
projects and hopefully I'll be able to
expand that in the future as
well thinking about doing a PhD when I
finish my
masters do you get to do it any faster
because you have a masters
like I know at MIT basically if you do a
masters first you're screwed because
like you've spent the extra year or two
to do a
master's uh assuming you didn't just do
it during your
undergrad no uh that's
rough yeah that's
rough I think it actually makes it
harder to get into a PhD program as
well um so the exception would be like
if you did a masters in four years or
whatever in Europe so I do a PhD in the
US that's pretty brutal because
like in Europe it's you
do in Europe correct me if I'm wrong you
do undergrad then you do like two years
for Masters and then two or three years
for PhD right in the US it's like the
PHD is one program where sometimes you
get a master's along the way but if you
already have a masters from somewhere
else it's still going to be a 5-year
PhD so basically you're in school until
you're 30 if you do uh if assuming you
haven't done like any job stuff in the
middle which is really
rough two years of Masters then PhD
yeah I
mean doing a pH in the US after that is
rough frankly
right like if you just did your if you
had like a good offer in
Europe that would be reasonable because
then you'd still be done in a reasonable
time
frame right because you have the Masters
and then it's just like two years or
three years or whatever but undergrad
then Masters then five years of PhD
that's a decade of
school right
do you know about any interesting labs
in Europe working in RL yeah there are
some I think the major affiliation in
Europe is that like deep mind is there
you get paid in your PhD so it's
somewhat like work
you get paid one tenth of what you would
make in
Industry the stiens are like 30 to 40K
in the US
usually yeah you
make yeah you're making like 3 400k
minimum even out of undergrad if you
have uh if you're coming from a good a
top university at
least particularly with a masters yeah
it depends a lot what your other options
are as well
um let me
think I'm I wanted to do this animation
like this uh this game animation type
stuff right
so let me go actually put on the water
for a little bit of coffee I've had too
much today already but like I'm not my
brain is just not working let me think
wait what time is it
2:47 I think I'll just crash harder if I
do that actually
[ __ ] whatever we we'll just we'll make
through it we'll get through this um let
me see
so
uh I think that we can do effects we can
do stun and we can do slow and we can do
speed buff as like overhead icons that's
easy we can do on hit effects as like a
flash a color flash that's easy if I as
soon as I get the asset I can do attack
animation I can do that that's
need I mean there are all sorts of
animations and stuff I could add but I
think that like that plus like having
like a decent map background and stuff
would already make it
substantially more
enjoyable I'm not going to spend like a
week trying to do like effects and stuff
that I don't know how to do right but I
could spend a few hours just like making
the thing at least relatively easy to
understand what's going on relatively
easy to play right um and then like
testing that everything works we
probably should get a map at some point
and we also need to patch a few things
with the current
map but yeah that seems reasonable to
me all
right so I think that we have to just
make the Sprite sheet then right we got
to make the Sprite
sheet this could be done relatively
quickly
what size are your
tiles you can render them whatever size
you
want I think the maximum is I think the
graphics are 128 by 128 so anything up
to that the assets will
rescale so here's our current Sprite
sheet
how big do I make this 256
256 that's too small 512
five
zero this is wrong it should be
panel there it
is
okay copy
paste what the heck is wrong with this
they locked
perer did you want to keep the aquatic
theme or ultimately make something akin
to platonic ideal stock fantasy I don't
know I kind of find it funny that like
the objective it's like you're playing
the puffer fish and the objective is to
get
Stars it's kind of like it's funny like
overthe toop obnoxious advertising for
puffer which I kind of like and I
already have like some assets for
it I think we're going to do this for
now and we're going to see how it
I think you can can you do like a line
is
like how I put these make these [ __ ]
align
maybe okay give me a few days hey if you
want to improve on this stuff that'd be
awesome
so this puffer is uh I can get you the
files for this I have higher res files
this is technically our logo so and I
have I have larger versions and I have
like an animated version of it so I mean
like you see the guy that I have right
here over the chat window right yeah so
like I have that
um so I was thinking that like maybe I
can take that I can like downscale it
and then like I can have like it
basically maybe I can separate I think I
should have separate swim files I don't
know how the artist gave it to me but
hopefully I have separate like swim and
puff files or maybe it's in a format
that can be separated so that I can have
like the idle animation be like swimming
or whatever like a three frame or like a
few frame like Loop for
swimming and then um you know maybe like
the attack will be like the puff
animation or something I figured like
something like that would be relatively
low effort and would like jazz it up at
least a fair
bit the other thing is that if I make
this render at least reasonably fast um
if I don't do like crazy stuff with the
effects then technically if I do
eventually Port this to c I could
probably make a from pixels train mode I
don't know if that's useful but I could
do it
aspite has some really nice tile export
tools all right cool yeah I can give you
all these
files including the source ones I'm
going to make a few little things for
now I need to get like some I'm just
going to go grab some stock stuff to use
and if you find better stuff that would
be
cool oh cool I guess people like it when
I post random [ __ ] throughout the day
I've heard people like asite for stuff
I've not tried it I don't know I took a
course in Photoshop in like high school
and I've just used it ever
since um right we need some icon packs
like I like this one I think that this
is for an existing game though isn't
it what is this
game that has really nice
icons oh it's a tank game that's so
funny they have really like these are
nice little icons I like
these I probably should not just be
using random games icons though
huh um what's the
I can look on what is it is it itch
like
no where's this on is it on itch no it
is on itch right yeah
okay I stun
icon wait that's what I pinged you on
Discord hold
on let me see wait ah I lost all my
windows hold
on where's the
Discord tizzy over a RI
oh wait what why do I not see
these
dang why do I not
see Discord
anything oh I see this is you
let me read
yeah that's awesome I'll definitely take
you up on
that and for reference the plan is in
the future I do want to add like
bounties for code stuff but maybe even
asset stuff around puffer um the deal at
the moment is while I am making negative
dollars um there are not going to be any
bounties but you know as soon as as uh I
get Revenue there will be bounties
that's not like a you know a back pray
promise or anything but if you want to
contribute absolutely that would be
awesome I will show you um I'll show you
cuz I do I don't just rip random stuff
like I'll rip random stuff for testing
and then I'll go pay for something
better is usually what I do um I'll show
you what I did for I have another
project that is not public yet
that I might be able to show you
privately um
but I'll show you what I used for
it I don't know if you know this guy's
assets has a whole bunch of it's like a
they're a bunch of assets that are all
in the same style and they have like
Sprite sheets and stuff for characters
so I used this before for a project um
and it it looks quite good but it was
just it was a ton of work to get
everything working together cuz like I
had to deal with so much stuff I'm not
used to like I there was like just to
give you an idea to get like the
character generator for a thing I had to
like do a whole bunch of processing on
like hundreds of different Sprite sheet
files and then like collate and
procedurally layer them together and
then like export layered versions of
everything just to get stuff to like
just to have the characters load it was
quite a bit of work
trust me on this Pono
awesome well I do have a history of I'll
show you as proof I do list non-
technicals as
contributors here are the two people
from upwork that did the original
puffer and here's the paid designer that
did uh this not this website did a
different website
people and I help promote where I
can pain especially when you can't reach
out for
edits yeah it's tough It's also when
stuff is like it's very hard to find
something in a style that you like for a
project that has enough work in that
area right because you need something to
be like one art style so I could never
find like I can never find packs for
substantial projects that have like all
the stuff that I would want to have um
together like so I just end up like
using whatever is the closest or
whatever is the most
cohesive um I've done stuff in the past
where
like hold on let me find like the art
pack that I really
there was like some really good
stuff is it these
good but basically like I'll do this
thing right where like I'll go looking
for art to like even if I like try to
buy stuff right I'll go like looking for
art to buy and like I'll find something
that looks cool like okay this is cool
right like these look really
interesting this is like kind of flat
not super noisy right like these look
good I could do something with at least
several of these but then like you know
this person will like only have potions
or only have like a few things and then
they'll just be like nothing else in a
similar art style stuff like that will
happen very often so yeah it's it's very
difficult even to like just make like
small amounts of graphics for uh like a
research Sim like
this because without having like a
dedicated artist on stuff it's like
getting stuff consistent is nuts hey lab
welcome kit bashing issues yeah it's
tough I did I'll I will show
you remind me remind me on the Discord
like Ping me if I forget um I got to go
rebuild it and stuff but I can show you
like the the project that I was working
on where I just used the Mana seed
assets and like it came out well but it
was a ton of work and like was it
exactly what I wanted not really like
does it look good yeah
mostly yeah I don't
know it's quite
tricky but I do plan on doing a lot more
Sims and stuff in the future as well for
this so it's going to be a problem I'll
have to figure out um so like briefly
one of my big plans with puffer right
and I have a video upcoming on this but
my idea here is that if we just get
enough different simulators like the
MOBA is one snake is another snake's a
really simple one we have a few in
between that are like medium complexity
but if we have like 10 of these that are
diverse and interesting and some are
really hard and some are really easy and
some are in between and they're so fast
that we can just run comprehensive
experiments overnight then RL is just
solved because we will no longer be in a
place where you have to spend two months
to validate whether anything is correct
or not and like you're publishing just
papers that are wrong because the
experimental evidence is just too weak
to support anything like things will
just be instantly conclusive and at that
point like you don't even have to worry
about algorithms anymore or any of the
science side because the progress just
becomes inevitable right just by like
instantaneous speed of iteration like
the progress just all becomes
inevitable so that's what I'm I'm
looking
at and I'm trying to build out the open
source Community around this like we
have Tech I suppose now non-technical as
well but we have you know a couple
people that are starting to contribute
simulators to puffer um Noah is doing
breakout Nathan's doing pong they're
both super high uh super high
performance Nathan's talked about
another type of SIM that I'm interested
in I've got a couple other PhD students
I'm pitching on like hey we should
collab on a different Sim right like so
this stuff can go pretty darn fast once
it gets going um yeah it can go pretty
fast once it gets
going and I'm trying to keep my own time
like as available as possible to just
Dev as much as I can at some point I'm
going to have to do a little bit more
business side stuff just to make sure
that puffer you know Contin and is able
to grow but the goal is I am Technical
and I want the majority of my time to be
like push RL forward hard just shove RL
forward hard as I
can so if that's exciting to you you're
in the right place and um the way that
we're doing it is also fairly accessible
to at least like pick up a few of the
basics and understand how stuff is being
doing uh is being done here because like
basically all the results that I have
here come out of just ultra high
performance engineering plus simple
experiments that are just run really
fast and that's a heck of a lot easier
to understand than the people that are
writing pages and pages of math on like
very fancy technical algorithms right
that may or may not work
often okay we've bored now that we've
sufficiently bored the entire
stream we should probably do a little
bit of
stuff I'm going to grab a couple free
assets on it just for now to use his
placeholders
let me just pick one of these for now
that's like relatively at least not
ridiculously clashing with this and then
we'll do because we'll have a few
screenshots in
this
uh oh this cool
cutesy and that's it so I guess this is
our only
oh these are AI generated
anyways that's
funny I'm actually surprised he even got
these out of
Dolly H just give me this for now we'll
use this for
Now tracking Captain doing the exact
thing I thought to myself needed to be
done as soon as a gentic behavior hit
mainstream ping me with Styles you like
after stream yeah I mean I will if you
have like stuff to link me I can I can
look at some stuff you've done and see
you know what stuff would
match that's awesome though I love it
when like there are people that are like
non-technical but are like just really
interested in this stuff and like to
contribute because a lot of the time
like I will get really hung up on non-ch
stuff that I'm just bad at um for
instance we had a we had a tech writer
uh Rose help us a ton with like neural
MMO stuff that was super valuable she
basically like sat down was like Hey
nobody can read your docs cuz nobody can
read your mind and nobody's been like
thinking about this MMO that you've been
developing for seven years so like let's
look at that and actually did a a great
job with the docks for the last
competition um so that was really cool
had a few other things like that in the
past
um at some point I'm going to have to
figure out the video thing as well
um maybe I will maybe I'm not so I'm one
of the Shor of short-term things which
I'm kind of doing is the last thing
before I officially launch puffer as a
company and like at least open it up so
maybe some companies will want like uh
support contracts with us and we can
start getting some Revenue um is I want
to put out like a video that's just
going through sort of my thoughts on the
current state of reinforcement learning
why everything is broken and outlining
exactly how puffer is fixing stuff at
every level so I have the script for
that the script writing for that took me
that took me like two or three days I
don't know if anybody could have made
that part faster CU I'm a pretty decent
writer uh already but then like oh my
gosh the like sequencing and the video
editing and all that stuff is just so
freaking terrible and I'm so bad at it
um
and it's like one of those things where
I don't want to just like get someone on
up work to do it because like I know
that people get good editors and stuff
and like get good people to help them
with stuff at reasonable like reasonable
enough rates for like you know pretty
like medium medium high quality content
but it's so difficult to just like find
those people when you're not in the
space right because half the time you'll
go like get somebody Contracting and
they'll just like give you garbage and
it's like well [ __ ]
hard like to get the puffer fish
designed even though like just to get
the puffer fish logo design that was
like multiple hundred messages with two
different
designers just to get like the one
puffer fish modeled and like the the
animation for it it was like three plus
week of like having to go back and forth
with
stuff drove me
nuts for stuff that's like way heavier
like that I am willing to pay reasonable
rates um I'm just not looking to add
like thousands of you know thousands of
monthly drain to the budget quite yet
until we at least have some Revenue
going in coming
in as soon as we do then like you know
it'll go back into the company
but the spend has already been pretty
crazy
okay these are too big these icons
should
but the boxes
right I mean the boxes are really cheap
for what they are but it's still 35k
right at the end of the day it's still
35k
those were such a good investment though
just the amount of work we've been able
to get out of them I mean especially if
we hadn't gotten hit with the crazy
Intel issue which is like a the Black
Swan event
right got a bail for now keep talking
shop God be G thank you very much thank
you for dropping by
okay questioning is box B for bad as it
seemed seg fault
twice I mean at this point they're going
to figure it out
right though I am going to be mad if I
had to send back perfectly good Hardware
I don't think I have I've seen like
things get screwy before
yeah is this all the icons I need no
right there's like
[Music]
clearer
okay let's uh let's get these integrated
then spasing out a little bit here
over
assets and I now need to do the mapping
don't
I so it
was actually all the current ones are
the
same I just have to move the tower one
which was this one I think
two this is now going to
be 0 to 56 I
believe 2 56 and then uh the
yeah so right here this one is now going
to
be 384 128 I
believe these are
neutrals and then yeah we'll see if this
is good
we should probably pull the latest
policy as
box
flash mile
okay now we have our model let's see if
it works
cool what character am I playing is this
not the
tank looks like it
maybe looks like it roughly
works okay so now we can start adding in
the new icons
okay so this was
[Music]
playing assassin or whatever yeah this
is fine
but this is the
tent let's see if this does anything
this should give you a tint if it's
being
hit oh yeah look at
that you can see they get uh they get
tinted did I get tinted when I was was
being
hit I didn't look at that I wasn't
looking at
that oh yeah yeah yeah it
flashes that's kind of cool
stun timer greater than
[Music]
stun
is
[Music]
z
8 we have
slow which is 0 to
okay move
timer R than zero and this want I have
to check cuz I forget how this
speed mods equals like
this entity. stun Tim or greater than
zero
we just draw them on top of each other
like
works and am I playing the right class
to
test there should be an assassin which
is class two
put like this
here now this should make it easy to
test because I have a move
buff uh it doesn't seem to be rendering
my move
buff also my respawn
doesn't clear cool
Speed wait X
is this is totally wrong
right 0 128
go it needs um
we need to offset it a little bit I
TX
Ty so TX
want it's pretty
nice see if this is reasonable it should
be to the left of the icon
icon you can see the speed buff on here
right and now we should be able to see
yeah they're like getting hit they're
getting hit
chaos I just took damage after I landed
so I think that they're like it's a
combination of there still being some
bugs and things just being a bit Jank
speed feels
good I also probably need to just get
the frame rate to be better because like
yeah I need to do frame
interpolation 100% that matters because
this is I think this is running like 5
FPS or
whatever I need to do frame
interpolation 100%
that so buff icons are there we need to
do heal icons we need to do a few other
things and we need to do like background
whatever stuff right
sure they're also shaders and [ __ ] we
can mess with
right
yeah all right all right uh so what
we're going to do I'm going to go use
restro real quick uh it's 3:40 so I'm
going to go make myself a shake and then
I'll be back in a few minutes and um we
will try to get the game so it feels
reasonable enough to play I think uh
we'll probably figure out like frame
interpolation we might figure out
background stuff a little bit we might
do a couple shaders we're just going to
get the game in a spot where it
generally feels okay to play and then
we'll go from there I'll be right
back
haven't had a malt from Brams in over 1
million
seconds
what when you
have 4096 M's like with snake doesn't it
become a lot harder for the agent to
learn because it sees 40 96 M's all the
time I mean yeah it takes more samples
probably I could go into the theory on
that but like you don't benefit as
strongly anymore above a certain batch
size but the thing is the samples are
basically free because the GPU is not
going to take any longer to process 4096
samples than it will take to process
2048 the data package are just so so
small so the data is basically free
anyways and it's strictly better it's
like going to be at least as good if not
better compared to having half that
number environments so you basically you
just win and for something like the Moa
having 4096 environments in the Moa
that's actually really helpful because
since the problem is way harder the
gradients are way noisier which is just
effectively a way of saying like you
need to play more games of DOTA to
figure out how to play DotA than to
figure out how to play Snake so yeah
it's actually very helpful so we're kind
of like the way I do everything right
I'm designing for the problems of now
but I'm keeping the problems of tomorrow
in mind and like as you scale the harder
problems um you can still simulate them
fast but you also benefit more from
simulating more in parallel so yeah
that's the longer version of it
the hell is oh this isn't bad okay this
is
cool very nice I will look through these
later I actually like this stuff
okay that's a nice
artist it's
awesome okay let's pull the stream back
up and we're going to have to figure
some hard stuff out not that hard
where's the target
FPS Target FPS is set to
real agent speed is
0.5 I should be moving five steps per
second then shouldn't
isn't the observation space a lot bigger
than just one n isn't that a problem
because they may get huge the
observation space is not bigger it's
just the replicas the number of
observations the observation space is
the same
um
so the observation space for
snake is uh a 11 by 11
crop of uint8 so 121 bytes so
4096 uh it's you have 496 time 100 400
kilobytes roughly 500 kilobytes whatever
um that is such a small packet of data
that you basically get that for free
like it would not
run it would run like almost 500 times
slower if you just cut the batch size by
500 and went to
eight and yeah it would learn faster in
samples maybe but it would be way slower
to train
overall if you want to read a good post
on
this they used to have more cool
interactive demos but they nerfed their
website I'll link
it this is a good blog
post so basically the extra samples
aren't going to really help you a ton
with snake but they're not going to hurt
either that's why snake it's like why
why does it take you know 200 million
times to to train stake snake well
because um you know we're using these
ridiculous batch sizes but who cares
because 200 million steps yeah it takes
200 seconds it takes like three or four
minutes to train right um but with
bigger M's harder M's like with a MOA
then the optimal batch size like you
could want to have millions of
batch so it scales very well with M
complexity which is why I designed for
that setting primarily
FPS not
five that's probably a
mistake that would explain why I was
underestimating certain damage values as
well
but like I should be able to just like
blink strike this guy
what do I do when it only calls
render once per frame like this
I think I have to call it in a loop
don't
yeah do I have to record last position
last X last
y I think I do in order to do
interpolation
irritating I can do it though right and
it should make a difference
so I need to do last X last
y oops I can't put it at the top though
cool we initialize them to zero
somewhere
right I think I have to do it for every
entity type as well
I don't know why the [ __ ] it's doing
this
I'm sure there's going to be something
weird but we'll do it like this
anyways basically what I'm trying to do
here is if you save the last position
like on the last game tick and you save
the current position on this game tick
then you can actually simulate multiple
frames for every step and you can smooth
out the graphics so that you're not
locked to 10 FPS even if the game
internally is running at 10
FPS um yeah that's kind of
useful and then technically if you run
too big of models in the middle it can
hitch but then there tricks around that
as well
we do main
R
okay
see
last
plus so you see we have to do this
interpolation manually
here and I don't see anything here that
needs to be modified which is
fine and then this is
where right so here this is where this
gets to be a
problem we have to
do the x times tile
size toty x equals entity. last X
I wish that this would learn to like
perceptually group stuff
reasonably okay that's pretty
good and I'm sure we're going to have to
fix some stuff with this
but that's basically what we
want draw HUD
yeah let's see if this
works let's move this as well okay so
that doesn't
work let's see record has I forgot to
recompile
if we can at least get this to be 60fps
first that will make it substantially
nicer to
play and then we will think about I
don't know why I made it 10 ticks per
second internally that's kind of a
lot okay so this is actually smooth I
don't know if you can tell but it's
smooth when it within every single tick
it's just that
somehow it's like snapping back on every
tick at the same
time so let's figure out why that was I
think that's not actually that bad for a
first
portion what if I just do this portion
what
anything okay no
so the snapping is kind of weird right
I over
six this is correct this is float
division isn't it range of like one and
seven
actually yeah it should be one and seven
because that would cause Jitter I don't
think that that will fully explain the
problem
though maybe it
does now we have flicker as well which
is
weird so we'll have to fix the
flicker it is smooth I can tell it is
come
on this should not be that hard
right maybe I should watch it maybe I
can ascertain the type of
flicker they're actually almost
smooth wait is it just me or the actual
puffers over there
smooth they're smooth aren't
they if I just like go up here here and
like I chill look everybody else is
actually
smooth they're kind of fast and like
finicky right but they're very
smooth yeah like look at the look at the
minions they look pretty good there
might be like a One Flame one frame
flicker but I think it's just the camera
movement that's wrong
this oh okay I'm not a [ __ ] it's just
um I I literally just copied a thing
wrong when I paste it that's fine so
let's figure out why this is
disappearing once per tick this is
bizarre
of course this is not going to look
tremendously different on stream it's
just going to look a little bit smoother
but like the thing I'm doing now if
you've ever played a game at 10
FPS yeah it feels bad to play right so I
want to make this I don't necessarily
want to make this like a crazy
interesting or like pretty to look at
thing but like I would like it at least
to feel decent mechanically right I'd
like this to like I'd like somebody
who's played League or who's played DOTA
to sit down and be like oh okay there's
something here not like this is all of
Dota or this is all of league but oh
okay these are like reasonably designed
little classes and they play
decently you know like it's fun to hit
the speed boost on the Assassin and then
you can like blink strike on stuff or
like it's fun to you know it's fun to
like position and then like hit drop the
AOE heal on the support and then drop a
stun it's fun to like you know hit your
three buttons on uh on the burst
character and just like take out a big
group of minions and
chunk the opponent like that kind of a
thing that's what I'm going
for I'll be good
y all see anywhere where this would be
flickering last
y
plus this should be tick Frack Time Zero
CU last y last X is equal to last uh is
equal to X the tower shouldn't
move so why are the towers
oh let's get rid of the prints just in
case the prints are slowing it
down technically this is probably not a
super performant client it is written in
Python I could rewrite it and
see okay these are clearly flickering
like the 10x per second or whatever
is the puffer flick the puffer is not
flickering
right the puffer graphic is not moving
at
all it is flickering like a little bit
when I move
it what it's like nothing is like
flickering in and out like this though
right like this is clearly
different so somehow stationary objects
flicker in and out of
existence presumably it's this line
right if I just comment this it works
interpolation
oh ah I
see well that is
weird I guess these are probably not
getting set huh that's probably just
what's happening
last X is Tower spawn X last Y is to
spawn
is this hit right here the reset Logic
for the game this is a knit isn't
it oh I guess this is
why so let's just do like
this because they
yeah Power Dot
X let's just do
this see if this fixes
really I would thought that would have
fixed
it last
X is X
how am I like nuts here or something
just weird
weird oh I'm just
stupid I'm just stupid I forgot to
rebuild I bet that's what it is I bet I
just forgot to rebuild the
file you spend enough time coding on
stuff you get
stupid I haven't had enough time to like
go run and do stuff because I've been
recovering from the 50k and my body is
going to take another week before it
allows me to like do anything
properly oh yeah this is this is totally
it right
oh
actually it works but the camera
movement
two why is it just like it flickers just
just a little bit
right that feels pretty good I need to
fix like the little bit of like
flicker I think like there's one frame
off or
something maybe hold on I got to try a
couple things
wouldn't it be funny if I got bored and
just ported this all to see so we could
actually like link it on the stream and
you guys could play
it I should totally not do
ah this feels
worse I think I was correct before
this is not inevitable right this is
like
anti-aliasing it definitely feels like
the model is not sliding smoothly across
the
really yeah it's like flickering with
movement it's like almost there I think
there's like one frame that it's like
jumping
I think actually the zero I think
they're both technically correct come to
think of
it um but hold
on I think you technically get a little
bit better reaction time with 17 like
this
so whenever you do frame interpolation
like this you lag behind by the
increment of one tick of whatever your
game is like cuz so the way that it
works if you're not doing predictive
movement assuming assuming you're not
doing predictive
movement because that can be wrong the
way that this
works is that you instead of rendering
with a character where it is now what
you do is like the the server tick
happens right you know where the
character is supposed to be now but you
look where the character was on the
previous server tick and then you take
several frames to move it like one
increment at a time so technically if
the server runs um at 10 ticks per
second it will lag behind like the
movement will be outdated by 0.1 seconds
and if it's you know that gets worse the
slower the server is that said you know
this works with like run escape which
has 6 second tick
servers it becomes noticeable there but
it still
works I just want to figure out where
this is
flickering wait is it hold on is it the
camera that is flickering or is it
the it might just be the camera that's
flicking
flickering I should have checked
that let's go just sit right
here these let's see if the guys that
look like they're coming by are they
flickering do they look like they're
flickering when they're coming in
or do they look like they're moving
smoothly I can't quite
much you can definitely tell hold on if
I press
e it's like really obvious now that it's
flickering
right let's check both the camera and
the
local built this stupid thing so many
times and I still end up with flickering
bugs could it technically also be the
overheads that are flickering and not
the
characters I think I see both
bars uh I'm Computing it based on
the that's
is it like this one it's not this one
pixel
so start at
zero 1 through seven is wrong
actually isn't it yeah
because okay I think I have the
math here I'll explain in a
second I this doesn't fix it still but I
think that this is
better so I think what happens the way
that this
works if we just go to the client and we
walk through the render function here
so time Step Zero right your last y
is equal to your Y is Whatever It Is
Right Time step one you move ahead then
we have six frames where we have to
catch your position up to the previous
so we've already rendered you at your
previous
position and now what we do is we render
you so we render you at your previous
position then we render you
way no I'm dumb it's the same either way
it's the same it's just there's a
different there's a a onef frame
difference of like if I think the other
way is like lags you an additional one
frame behind it doesn't make a
difference I'm wrong
there should I increase the frame rate
to 120 just to
see what if I do 120 FPS and then I have
to set
the this is range 1 through 13 now I
believe and this is I over
now well the game actually feels
noticeably better except for the flicker
the puffer looks like it's
flickering it really
does what I can't tell is how big the
flicker is
is is this like a pixel level error
where it's just like it's off by a
pixel it doesn't look like it I think
it's worse than a pixel when you have
the speed
boost I'm pretty
sure that looks like it's multiple
pixels to me
I mean there is the integer
rounding one
pixel does that
unavoidable it's more likely that I have
something wrong with the camera
right should I take the int
here no
flicker okay
okay alternative
idea alternative
idea here's what we're going to do we're
going to run the Sim in super slow
motion but with high FPS does that make
and then instead of doing we're going to
do like 121
here no this is 120 right yeah one 121
so let's see if this does anything I'm
hoping that this will make it easier to
see if there's a bug
holy oh yeah there's definitely a
flicker here
do the other puffers look like they're
flickering too
camera so the other P the other puffers
might be like getting snapped to pixels
or something but the text is smooth like
they make these weird little movements
but the text is very smooth
I think that's kind of
okay the thing that bothers me is it's
like yeah it's clearly that it's like
screwing with the text so that means
it's in the camera motion
somewhere not the movement
be is it
wait could it be
because it moves the
camera no it doesn't
draw when I move the
camera it doesn't need to do a redraw
plus is it What minus
one
20 how about I just do
this does this do
anything is it like an off by one I
don't think it's Noth by one I think
it's flickering more than once per
second oh I could be wrong
welcome we're debugging
things and no fun will be had by
anybody until I fix this camera flicker
should I snap wait should I snap M this
to
ins God's gift to men
debugging yes
indeed the good news is I've had to do
less and less
debugging in the last few years but it's
still
obnoxious hold on wait is this did I do
it the text is no longer
flickering my text is no longer
flickering at least is the other text
flickering oh this is literally pixel
Precision isn't
it dude that's so obnoxious
flickering it looks like they are just a
little bit
it's
literally the camera has to be pixel
aligned I
think that might fix the bulk of it to
be honest but smoothness is very
important it really affects the feel of
the game if it feels like just a little
bit choppy it's it really screws it
up like more than me spending a bunch of
time on on anything else like it makes
sense to do to make the game
smooth like you can have a super basic
game with a super basic Loop but if it's
smooth and it's fun it's good
right what else makes a game good I
don't know being
fun it has to just like feel good to
play I don't
know depends who you ask
my favorite games are all games that are
just like they feel good to play like
they're just tight
the movement is too slow now where
you're noticing the individual pixels so
let me go let me set the frame rate back
to something
reasonable and let me see how it looks
like that CU I like I could already be
done here it could already be
fixed okay so 120
FPS is going to
be
13 IDE by 12
movement feels good for my character now
it's actually very
solid um I can't tell for the M the AIS
cu the AIS are already super spam me I
got to wait for the
minions speaking of which where the hell
are our minions
do those look
good or they
like I can't
tell they look pretty
I should probably set 60 as the default
because
devices and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to
to I'm going to keep this like
so because I want it to be five ticks
per
second so 12 * 5 is
60 12 frames per
tick is what we
get and now this is going to feel super
slow and we're going to have to tweak
stuff I think
um I don't know if this is running at
the intended speed
I think so I think this is five ticks
per second so now we have to adjust cool
downs and
[ __ ] but this is
better we're going to have to adjust
quite a few
yeah we're actually going to have to
rebalance a lot that was a big oversight
on my part but that's
okay this has a speed buff on it that's
weird yeah this this move speed feels
way better
fix we have to figure out like what the
heck this is for instance
make uh I should work on making this
feel a little better
first let's fix some of those like jump
bugs
okay so I think I know what's wrong so
move two this is going to cause a lot of
MOA so this function
here this is not responsible for
updating last
pause um Step has to
be so this type of a loop right here
this is what's needed
let's see if this makes it feel less
Jank
so this should get rid of
the yep you just get stuck on walls
cleanly
now there's no weird
[Music]
weirdness your coold Downs are like way
too long
yeah the Mana needs to come back
[Music]
faster I like how it like jump Cuts you
back to the spawn like that that's cool
that's just a feature of the last
position
stuff push
forwards it's pretty
good I think there's like you can
technically yeah you can jump through
walls like this if you go slow I if you
go fast you can just jump through that's
probably bad but we should fix that
probably um
yeah we should probably just fix that by
making the walls like one thick can I
jump through a full
wall oh you can just jump through full
walls that's funny it's because you're
moving faster than the
wall that's kind of cool though to be
honest I don't think that there should
be like these things that you can
technically like if you get it at just
the right angle you can get through
real let me see can I just get through
this yeah you totally can get through
walls if you go at just the right angle
cool it feels way better we can continue
to make some tweaks I think we should do
the uh some of the balance stuff at the
same time here because
like yeah I I messed a couple things up
earlier and I'm going to just have to
it's going to be a pretty easy rebalance
cuz I don't have to guess it's just like
a fix
scaling but I do have to do it
manually so we'll fix that we'll see if
we can make the game feel
better uh we should fix like hit
indicators and stuff and I'll be right
back from
good okay so what I have to do right now
is I for some reason I had the tick rate
in I didn't think I had the tick rate
set to 10 so this game was designed for
like the server
updating I thought I was designing for
the server updating five times a second
but apparently I was designing for 10 so
I have to
go
first I'm just going to go cut all the
cool Downs in
half and then I'm going to figure out
what I do about mana and stuff
technically the easiest thing to do
would just be to make you regain two
Mana per tick
right I don't know if I like that
versus
what cut all the Mana values in half and
then cut all of the cost the spell cost
in
half I also have to cut the HP in half
and the Damage values in half no that's
too much I think that we'll just double
the Mana
regen and the health regen or
whatever that'll be easy we can do that
real quick
and then we can mess with stuff later
but like I think for the initial pass
this will this will get the game into a
good spot
so this was supposed to
be oh wait no I already have this these
right don't
regain maybe these are right and they
just feel
slow I guess it's cu the Autos don't
feel
it's cuz the Autos don't feel good
right like your skills don't feel good
right now like it feels like you need to
be spamming skills because like you're
not actively doing your autos
I think that like having reasonable
Autos with some form of projectile is
probably necessary
right yeah I'm going to have to do
reasonable
Autos okay what about the Mana and
health
regen right now I'm
regening five health and five Mana per
second what is it actually in
Dota I guess it varies by level doesn't
it let me check
people are mad on Twitter because I say
that coding in llms is
Fun Health
regeneration the
unit heals the unit in 0.1 second
intervals
ah okay so this actually helps a lot
so this base of like most Heroes here
have
0.25 this is 2.5 Health per
second with some of them being higher
and then this scales over the course of
the game
right so if I just double it to start
with is that crazy
um I guess we'll leave it for
now I guess it's actually kind of
correct
huh mess with some stuff
crazy okay um let me think then what
else we do I think we need to think we
actually need to think about
Autos so let's let's do
this can go inside the RB
client we're going to do we're going to
try to make this closer to DOTA movement
so it's click not drag and see like the
thing is the player just doesn't have
enough stuff to have to be doing so it
feels like you need to be spamming
skills cuz you're not like spending time
doing movement and stuff
how do we do
this I
like this
yeah then we do if self. net click is
not done then we do
d uh
x d y is last
click and
then
um. y minus hold
on what the heck is this
tall
size IDE by
tile but I don't want this to be here
right
it's like Mouse x
minus tile
size Game
uh uh we're going to have to figure this
out so last click is going to
be dest x dest
y and then we just do
a y
equals well let's just
do
dust minus
right this is like
obnoxious it's very obnoxious
there's no way to go to an
exact position I guess
X thank you bet yep all this stuff is
open source on that link you can go
ahead and Star Puffer it helps me out a
ton free way to support all this
I don't know I get like this like late
afternoon slump for a little bit
usually let me go check a couple things
hopefully clear my
head puffer so you can fix your PRS
to be fair bet there are PL there are
places in like places you should avoid
in engineering where you're just
required to work with standard tools
that are built to require [ __ ] tons of
boiler plate and it just
sucks if you're doing like substantially
lower level graphics even than RB if
you're doing like raw GL calls or heaven
forbid if you're doing like
um uh what's the other
one there are things in graphics world
that just require hundreds of lines of
boilerplate
government yeah
sure but generally yes there's generally
more boiler plate written by people than
is
required e
nah I'm so much stuck on the way that I
designed this
dumb I think I should just write
something for now
right yeah
I think you just clip this between
negative 1 and
negative and I think that you multiply
by three
I think it's three
plus this might be
and I fixed the other render
stuff already
okay let's just do
this this is
dy I just have to like write something
and not care about this because
otherwise I'm just going to be like
stuck staring at this
forever this is very simple I'm just
overthinking
things what's wrong I'm just trying to
make a different movement format
okay thank you for the
hallucination language model
if the text position is in fractional
pixels could that AFF yes it totally
could so what I tried to do is I just I
uh I aligned this camera itself to the
pixels that helped
substantially
um the thing is if you're moving things
very slowly on a not like super high res
window it's going to look weird cuz like
if you're moving like one pixel one from
frame and then two pixels another frame
it's weird you'd have to do like
trajectory smoothing I think but I got
it to look pretty good what I'm doing
now is something different I'm trying to
I'm experimenting with click movement
instead of drag
movement I'm attempting to experiment
with click movement instead of drag
movement apparently
we're just going to make this work real
quick otherwise I'm going to get
bored simple as that
the uh what I think was happening here
I'll share this in a second
oops I think it's you need to have click
movement it's a mooba you just need to
have click
movement um the drag movement was cool
and it actually felt pretty good but the
thing is like when you have drag
movement and auto targeting and
everything like there's nothing to do in
the game like you're just like holding
the mouse towards the enemy and then
clicking your skills and then the skills
go on 12 second cool Co downs and like
there's nothing to be doing
seven okay I
miscounted
screen what are you looking at I wasn't
talking about the alignment of this text
I was talking about the alignment of
like the text in the
game does my stream text look bad on
YouTube
I'd hope
whatever we're going to just test this
because otherwise like I said I'm going
to get bored doing this and I just like
lose focus because I get bored
well there you go this is in pixel space
somehow that's
weird it's actually funny I'm pretty
sure that I'm more tired when I don't
run 50 miles a week than when I do run
50 miles a week isn't that
nuts do your exercise folks it's good
for
you I will hopefully be back to my
normal routine pretty
[Music]
stairs
uh I mean I tell folks seriously like
the best decision I've made in the last
several years has been getting in proper
shape like proper shape as
well which takes quite substantial
effort but literally like even when I
have like when I have to like recover
for a week or two from something it's
just the
worst like in my head I know yeah my
body is just totally thrashed it's going
to take like two three weeks to fully
recover minimum but like I want to be
doing stuff already again
right not lean key shape I got too much
skinny you can lift weights there the
thing you can do
I want to get my deadlift back for
sure I have like I've spent like I've
sacrificed way too much lower body
strength training with the running so
I'm going to build back the strength
with the running
now a circle is a shape
true what the heck is wrong with this
so raw Mouse
over how Fu does this make any sense
chat
jippy I guess this is super
Maven this is divided they should not be
multiplied isn't it
this
no I literally like I don't know what I
had in my head I thought it was going to
be like oh yeah 50k it'll take a week to
recover
nope it does not take a week to
okay folks audience participation time
what am I being stupid
with
this is your position this is your
position relative to the
camera in pixels
right then you divide by the tile
size do I just not need to do this is it
just Mouse X
maybe we don't
uh maybe we don't do uh in division
maybe we do float division here so it's
more
and then
what this
it let's
see for
I know how we're going to fix this as
well so this is I got it and
it's I got to like take a minute or
something to clear my head I don't know
what the hell's wrong with me I'm like
it's probably because I ran out of
regular milk so I made this shake with
chocolate milk it's probably just
falling asleep from a [ __ ] ton of
sugar my
guess I got to take a second and then
what we we're going to do is we're going
to make it so that the EnV accepts
continuous valued it's going to accept
continuous valued action inputs for the
movements um even though the policy is
currently doing discreet it'll do
continuous in the
future
and the reason for this is that we need
to convert from continuous to uh
discreet other the way around we need to
convert from discret to continuous so
that for the human player it can always
be in continuous mode because otherwise
you have to like make these weird
turns coffee and a healthy dose of
Aderall [ __ ] no it's 5:41 p.m. man no
[ __ ] way I go to bed at like
9: I'm basically like you can think of
me as like the healthiest youngest
grumpy 80-year-old man you've ever
seen all right I'll be right
fix car what on Earth is BET on about
what are you doing
discretize we're going to have to make a
few changes
so we're going to make the action Vector
a float
we're going to say that this is going to
be actions
continuous then we're going to take all
this
stuff oops
here and we're going to assume that this
is all like
garbage and then we're going to
even more
comments we're going to assume that this
transformation is done already for
yeah okay and then we're going to just
do self.
and then slash
equals slash equals
3 I believe
so running a sweep with too many total
time steps gives me a type
error I don't see the error
sure it's you set total time steps
bigger and that happens
I can't think of anything that would
cause
that wait you said that that's fewer
total time steps you went down from 100
billion to 100 million
odd I can't think of anything that
causes that off the top of my
head there shouldn't be that's that's
not the batch size
though so I can't think of what would be
unless somehow it's like getting it's
like overflowed something or whatever
but I doubt it
let's see if this does what I think it
does and then I guess with the human
code here we can
[Music]
do hold
on with the human code here so what I
this is why I wanted to do this so I
know longer have to do this [ __ ]
operation
here um I can just
do
clip I can just clip from negative 1 to
one and now this is
zero and I'm sure we're going to have to
fix some stuff with this but
if this works I'll actually be able to
save probably 30 lines of code outside
of the
Moa buffer expected int but got
float right that's fine I know how to
fix
huh expected int got float no it
shouldn't expect
that doesn't make
sense actions continuous is type float
here right
I bet it
is I bet that the thing I should be
doing
is yeah let's try this
there's a little bit of subtlety here as
to how we handle these data
types
so I think instead what I'm going to do
here
so we take this as a
float and we
do minus first of all it's not discreet
anymore just actions and we do minus 100
divide by
okay uh now this is already an INT I
believe but I'll leave that just in
oops
cool so now we have to update the data
types here
this so we use the discrete Vector here
to
store um but then we do actually keep
this
discretize but only for the
I think I get to do hold
on subtract
three I think it's the other
way I think it subtract three and then
multiply by 33
now we'll see this might be do something
silly I'm sure that will be be
thoroughly
amusing yeah because it's going to give
us the incoming discreet actions are
going to be -3 or they're going to be 0
through seven so you subtract three to
center it and then you time you multiply
by 33
and then we do dy over
here so now this does have to get Scaled
but I think the scaling is easier
maybe it's not an unsigned integer right
can't I just hold on
I don't have to subtract 100 right I can
just divide by
100 I can just take float divide by 100
like this
right
yeah cuz all I have to do is scale it I
don't have to center it
anymore okay so that's actually very
easy because now Dy and DX I clip from
Nega -1 to one and I just multiply by
100 let's see if this does
anything or if we still have more to
fix welcome YouTube
folks just run no doesn't work uh okay
let's
see different extents in dimension
one 11 and zero
I assume this is something that's moving
super fast and just like
teleporting I think if I need to
recompile that's probably it I just have
the Velocity set way too high
it why is it do
this this literally does RuneScape
pathing what the hell
discretizing it feels like it's still
discretizing right
feel like it's still
discretizing let me see
why it should be relatively continuous
now for
linky do you see what I mean it's like
it's doing like the long it's like doing
the diagonal then it's doing the short
then it feels like it's still being
discretized can you even go straight up
you can go straight
up you should be able to go straight up
though
things there's no reason it shouldn't be
a straight
am I wrong in the way I'm thinking about
this hold
on
like oh I'm just
stupid guys it's fine I figured it out
I'm
stupid we're good to
I don't think I should have trusted the
norm
am I doing this
right we'll
so the jumps are uh just like a random
thing that I have it don't worry about
that those will go
away I not have Mana I have Mana for
that one
there that that was the
ability okay this feels a lot more like
a Moa
we're going to have to test the
abilities with the new movement and
stuff but this actually does feel like
substantially a different game
already just having to click around
constantly actually makes it feel
dramatically
different so I was right it was the
movement and the movement it still feels
good uh I should make it so that you can
hold click to drag as well right
because that's the thing isn't it hold
click to
move yeah so now you can hold click and
it'll still move you
back yes assassin can actually clip
through
walls I'm not sure if it's a feature or
a bug
the Mana is like brutal but I guess this
is like level two
gameplay so you can't really use your
skills all that
much like I'm spamming q but I can't
press it because I don't have the Mana
can you still pull Towers yep we left
that
in viewers said they that we should
leave it in so we
did okay this feels like pretty
reasonable though why can't I uh oh I
can use my e why do the buttons not like
always react for me
this fixes
it lot of Cru
why did I just get a big bump off of my
Mana without actually doing anything
we got to just test out the buttons a
little bit
here okay so it's
not it's not like saving the actions
obnoxious I see why the inputs are
clunky
I honestly think that the
uh the cleanest thing is to just put the
entire render in a loop
we'll figure out how to clean that
later yeah we'll figure out how to clean
that later but like
and dend all of this code which I hate
doing we'll have to refactor it somehow
but currently it was causing a pain in
the ass
um cuz what we need to do
is like these things up
here these need to go at the top
we'll see what happens with this I'm
sure we're going to have to fix some
stuff but as soon as I get the key binds
to like feel
nice as soon as the keybinds feel nice
like I think the game is just it's going
to come together all of a
sudden I've seen it happen
before
huh old ultra
speed this is kind of
funny I don't know why it's putting my
things on cool
down it's very
weird let's go figure out what the
hell's
I need
this who let the puffers get into the
speed
storage the puffers are
fun puffer MOA is best
MOA bestselling MOA of the
Year we're just going to top the
charts everybody's going to be playing
puffer
MOA that'd be funny as
hell I mean if crab game if like crab
game with guns can win can like puffers
with turrets not win
like I don't know why it's actually fast
to be
snippy ah I see the
problem I see the
what
the oh
weird why is it randomly using my skills
again I didn't press the E button
you're about to get them Wireless hands
through the screen linky
yeah like the neural that's definitely
taking over for me
did I put a return in here earlier or
something
stupid no
is
all right I don't know let's just see if
it says I'm printing it let's just see
what it thinks I'm freaking
and really just [ __ ] refactor I don't
know that's kind of
bizarre all right let's see about
this does the game work now
it's a little awkward when it like jumps
you
there a few like inconsistencies with
the path
this feels substantially better not
perfect yet but substantially
better okay there's this level one over
here let's see can I go catch
why yeah that's pretty cool that you can
just jump to it the jump feels good now
as well I
I don't know how I can do
um a little bit of the movement stuff is
good it just needs like a few
tweaks like that's good right there see
like jumping to
Target it slowed me but I survived on
like third health is good
and then like here I got to like wait a
little bit and then maybe I had have
Mana for this except he hit me before I
could hit
him so now I try to get
back I try to W the other puffer where
is
he yeah I try to go around and like do
this and apparently I get one shot
there it's not bad it's not bad we need
to fix a few
things I'm wondering with the jump
ability how um
it basically I think it needs like hit
like damage like take damage animation
or something it needs like heal
animation and a couple other small
things I guess I just what time is it
it's already 6:37 okay so I think what
we'll do here then is we
will I think all we're going to do is we
like man I would have thought I could
have gotten more done on this I guess I
did balance like the whole thing did I
huh and I fixed a bunch of stuff with
the renderer so that's not
terrible
um let's just play the remaining classes
to see if they feel reasonable and then
we will launch like another sweep of
sorts on this overnight to see if it's
uh if it's remotely balanced now or yeah
what gives
basically do we want to fix the neutrals
as
well we might want to fix
neutrals let's do that real
I'm also I'm tempted to do this without
the distance
reward because that's like what's just
making him run down
mid so maybe will do that as
reward okay so we get the respawning up
here
but these aren't on the board right yeah
they're like here but they're not here
it's weird
them which is why they're
here but they don't do anything they sit
here and they don't have the
tile I think this is
pid1 move
to let's move to
do we
okay you see that the pit is wrong it's
all negative 1es
I'm actually wondering now if the game
is like meaningful enough that we can
train without the distance reward that'd
be really good
I just saw it print all the stuff I
wanted and then it freaking deletes
it okay so this is
you can see all the IDS right
here I assume this is for all the
different games
I'm going to check one more thing I'll
spend one more compile cycle on
this God damn it wrong [ __ ]
command come
on
there okay good this is what I was
looking
for it's one through
72 so they have good pids
it we want to see the neutrals on the
map after all
there I can see that you're on the map
and that your last position has not been
set correctly
this think this
works I think we're going to go see some
neutral
Puffs neutral Puffs what's up
you guys are kind of buff aren't
you I think H I just barely lived the
neutral
Puffs they were kind of
Mana cool
though we got the neutral Puffs back
they're uh in Gray
now they look very snazzy
technically you can dive a neutral puff
like
this and uh you can realize that you
have no mana and then get merked because
you're bad at your own
game and then I can take two of them out
122 XP
jungling took got the Assassin there
prettyy
cool okay
um time is it
52 let's get this sweep I think let's
get this thing running at least
this okay
so we
rebuilt and we're going to see what
happens here whether it learns anything
at all without the distance reward and
then in the meantime we get to play some
mooba to play some MOA classes
oops Yeah we're going to try them all
real quick the support is uh index
one what are our
abilities we have a hook and AOE heal
and a
can I heal my own
Tower if I have
see I don't know if that healed the
tower it definitely healed everyone else
though
ability the Mana is really
rough I kind of want to just double Mana
regen it just seems very stupid at the
moment
let's just double Mana regen and see
what the hell happens right
they are actually doing stuff with this
seed Isn't that
cool actually they are leveling up and
doing stuff now without the uh the
distance
reward so it actually doesn't need the
distance reward that's really cool maybe
they won't just go down mid who
knows I want to hammer the heel button
like it owes me rent
money so I'm support so I Stay stay back
I'm not going to just die to this wave I
am going to save this puffer in a second
though so I just saved my
puffer I'm going to save my Mana for the
AOE heal because it's really op unless
this puffer is going to in which it is
my puffers are inting please
help oh it's it has me stunned
[ __ ] I shouldn't use that cool down I
still have a
stun oh look at that we got him we got
him with the long
stun okay this is actually kind of fun
like obviously it needs a couple
animations and like some Polish and
stuff but this is kind of
fun so this class is just
two class two is burst that should
actually be super fun it has a nuke and
AOE and an AOE stun I think it's a
little bit Mana hungry at the start of
the
game is the only
thing that's how it's balanced cuz
otherwise it's
broken but I'm pretty sure we can just
like wreck a fool
with this
class we have a pretty strong
AOE we have a nuke so we're just going
to like drop this and then we're going
to get next to this guy uh I think we
missed I think we accidentally nuked Dom
minion we still have the
AOE and we have this stun There He Is We
got the stun
off come on do I have Mana for
nuke I think it's
150 stay in XP range
here of course we actually have to get
the last hits ourself which is a little
tricky and then I have to get around to
like this puffer and I have to Nuke it
like this oh look at that look at that
burst I just two I just two tapped that
good I'm happy with it and then we have
the tank what's the tank got has a AOE
damage over time a stupid strong Health
uh self heal and an engage
AOE when I play things I generally do
like to play the
tank so let's see if this is fun
the only thing is we don't have a lot of
Mana so I think we just walk into fools
actually let's see if we can Farm I
think the tank should be able to Jungle
pretty well you see this AOE
here look at that oh this is the jungle
character 100%
look at
that we're already level three we're low
on Mana is the only
thing yeah this is op as [ __ ] holy
hell let's try the
engage oh look at that we can just
engage and then jump on them with the
damage over
time get
wrecked he stuns me he stuns me and runs
away
okay this class is actually
sweet okay actually this is really
freaking good this is actually kind of
fun like if I put halfway decent
animations or graphics on this this
would literally be like a ton of
fun uh and then there's the carry okay
the carry is just not going to be any
fun um
it really doesn't have very much it just
scales but we'll play it anyways we have
to figure out a way to make the carry
fun I think like it's just like a
scaling
character AI will pick up on sending
tank to Jungle I I think it
might it without the distance reward it
probably will like right now it's just
farming the distance
reward okay so here's the carry it's got
an AOE
right it's got to slow so I can slow
down the thing it's got to retreat does
that do I have a
retreat I can't use
this well it just kills
see maybe this ability just doesn't
work I don't know why just lost
pursue I use the AOE on
it I think the que just doesn't
work that's no big deal though the carry
is still broken it's just not fun yet it
scales like crazy it's like it's a carry
right it's what you'd expect
oh and I just got one shot by whatever
that was because I only have 300 health
so I guess the carry is supposed to just
like M don't know go farm some [ __ ] it's
not very good at farming [ __ ] but
like it can't really do anything early
it needs to be supported by the team and
if the team isn't supporting it it kind
of just needs to like go get XP
somewhere it scales like
mad yeah see I'm going to die just from
these like minions here cuz I just don't
have any
tools we got to rework its queue into
something it's supposed to have like an
escape tool and it's
q but for now I think this is pretty
good like they level up they do stuff
right let's just add this let's just add
the double
mana and then what we'll do
is here's what we'll
do yeah the tank feels really
good honestly a lot of the classes feel
really good like the burst character
feels really good just needs some
animations it's like it's a burst
character it's very bursty uh the
Assassin character has like the cool
jump TP effect and it has the speed
boost that's really
fun um the support has this really
strong like team heal ability and it
also has like a really strong single
Target
stun um what did I
forget car's not super fun the rest of
them are good
though it's also committed to GitHub so
you can technically go play
it doesn't use the support
stun no it uses the support uses
its the support doesn't have a stun wait
yeah it does which it doesn't use you
said I thought it did use
it it doesn't use it a ton but it does
use
it so what we're going to do is we're
going to just comment this parameter out
of the sweep so it's not going to reward
distance it's going to be set to zero
here
and then total time
steps uh I think this might be too
short 100
million let's do like 200
mil and we'll just see what happens
overnight I mean
what do you mean how do you get it to
pick bells for the numbers that don't
break
it what numbers would break
it yeah there going to be some numbers
where it doesn't learn anything but
that's
that won't happen with sweep
carbs I I had some issue not I have some
issue keeping sweep and sweep carbs
working at the the same time bet because
wanb doesn't have official
support they really should by now
like
yeah I mean they both should work
technically but I haven't figured out a
good way to do
it so the thing is like this is the
thing that happens with companies right
like they get big they get these clunky
code bases like the way that think that
the way that you just win everything is
like you know something like carbs
releases you have support for it the
next
day want to be get to error very useful
come on man you got to do better than
that
YouTube I mean you can tell me to check
Discord
like you're allowed to do
that very
cool very cool UI here
I'm guessing it doesn't have all the
prams defined
it's going up but it hasn't beaten its
previous best here yet oh wait no is
this the old sweep wait this is the old
sweep right now this is a super old
[ __ ] uh
guys wait let me check the original
paper
Rider oh we wrecked them yeah guys we we
just wrecked them
totally yeah we just we just destroyed
them
and how many frames did we take actually
oh we destroyed them in literally better
sample efficiency we we' destroyed them
in like we literally made this thing
like 50 times faster in wall clock and
twice as fast in samples yeah we just
destroyed
[Laughter]
them I'm telling you like this RL thing
is not a bunch of fancy math like it's
literally just nobody's run extensive
experiments we just
win I'm sure that there are like better
scores on this like by specialized
methods and stuff but like I just ran
the most basic thing possible and I like
triple I more than tripled their score
and this thing isn't even done running
yet like this can potentially do way
better
them I've kind of just been like
allocating a box to running big Atari
sweeps cuz like everybody wants Atari
results uh and like like okay fine it's
slow but I made it relatively faster and
here you go we
win is just that
good this is carbs though not carp carp
that does magic is
Magikarp which is
they better have published the
individual
results I'm ignoring any paper that
doesn't publish their individual
results I'm just going to assume that
they made it up or
whatever don't care hopefully they have
a table
though I don't know how slow I think
that this thing like runs forever as
well
does this run like a billion frames or
something I don't
know oh this is actually funny they also
do without look at this look at this
they actually use sticky actions false
on
here I told you this setting is
funny I had like a couple people give me
some [ __ ] for like writing this article
like sticky actions considered harmful
look this is like one of the best known
papers sticky actions false right here
nobody gave them
[ __ ] all you have to do is put Deep Mind
on the top or whatever
do you think many researchers just
blindly copy hyper parameters from other
okay let's be a little more generous
than that it's not that they blindly
copy hyper parameters it's that their
libraries are so slow that they can't
afford to run hyper parameter sweeps
like Okay so this experiment here let me
just put this into context right this
experiment right here that I'm running
uh I've run this for one day if I were
to run this experiment with let's say
the default cleanar element
implementation it would take hold
makes which is a perfect time for me to
remind you all
puffer lib is free and open source
software available right here please
just start the
puffer helps me out a
ton really it's all I
ask puffer must be fed a consistent diet
of stars in order to grow large and
strong
seriously though it actually helps me a
ton because
like there are metrics that I use that
actually do end up mattering in like H I
don't know hard to explain
whatever this
work
ELO model
one 1482 ELO
logged no errors right
refresh why like and subscri well that
helps a little
bit there's also and I know that there's
not a like the YouTube audience a lot of
you guys are not on Twitter it's
mandatory for ML I don't like social
media either but but
um I do
have where are
these where are my published articles
isn't there like a tab that I can go to
stupid
UI oh yeah if you go to like articles
here I mean there's one non-te one
because I think that's important for
people but like I do have some articles
some of which are kind of technical some
of which have like unique insights like
you can't get this anywhere else you
can't get this any anywhere else like a
lot of these things are pretty
interesting and unique little and
they're light reads for the most
part yeah UI is crap look I've never
used social media in my life before X I
do not like it it is a huge net negative
to my mental health I hate it but the
thing is like this replaces
marketing like this this like actually
replaces marketing so not having to do
that and just being able to post a few
things is really
awesome so there you
go Twitter's great live streams on yeah
yeah yeah the live streams are better on
YouTube the Twitter like they don't even
have HD I'm pretty
see okay so they got some
levels but as expected like this is not
a a good set of hyper prams this is the
start of a new
goes socials are cancer but we got to
play the game
yeah you pick the games that you play
and you pick the games that you don't
right puffer definitely goes
bur I mean this is just such a nice
result
I mean let's let's put this into
perspective right so this run here I
click this
run watch
this so 25 million steps that's the
train but here's the
thing if I look at relative time
process this is only 13
minutes 25 million train steps an
original clean RL lstm
implementation um would be like 12 hours
not 12
minutes and clean RL was like the
awesomest thing out there yeah some
stuff was faster but it was really gross
to use so
like the speed is
good and it's a whole combination of
things as well it's not just like one or
two little tricks like I found some
better settings for Atari that sped up
the base environment but then oh no the
default vectorization actually
bottlenecks you there if you do it that
way so I have like entirely custom
vectorization for Puffer that works way
way way faster I have a paper on that
and then like oh no even if you have
fast vectorization the default train
settings are really slow well we've done
comprehensive experiments to find fast
train settings and then once you do that
like oh no you still have other various
things in the implementation that are
bottlenecking you like certain lstm
decisions the way they implemented that
or like the generalized Advantage
estimation we took care of those as well
and then after that it's like oh no
there's no logging you can't tell what's
going on we added a bunch of logging and
then after that it's like oh no there's
no easy way to tune hyperparameters we
added integration with carbs which is
the best algorithm out there that we
know of so like yeah there's a lot of
stuff that went into this but the cool
thing is it's now like a couple thousand
lines of total code and it just wins cuz
you get stuff like this out of
it this is training at over 30,000 steps
per second on one GPU compared to like
low thousands with like optimized
original implementations and hundreds if
you use like The
Originals so there you
go it's pretty
cool I'm a little sketched out by the
value losses on these
oh no my RL doesn't work but now there's
puffer Live support yeah that's how it
works
moa's in a very nice
spot MOA is in a very nice
it's 7:30 folks um I am going to go grab
food and then go to bed soon um does
anybody have any last minute burning RL
questions or other
things I was just sticking around to
make sure that this run isn't
crashing relatively new to RL what are
some ways to incentivize trying new
macro level actions for agents without
reaching local optim
trying new macro level agents okay so
there isn't
um I should explain the technicals on
this because I don't know your level of
background so in the majority of deep
learning uh local Optima are not a
problem because they do not exist in
high dimensional
space you can show that here's a really
a dumb down proof of it that I like to
show if you have like a 2D plane right
like you have like a 2d like a let's say
a 3D surface right you have like a bowl
yeah there's a local Optima but if you
look at every Dimension right is like uh
you can either go up or down in each
Dimension so it can look like this it
can look like this or it can look like
this here let me do it properly so each
Dimension right in uh in high
dimensional space you can look like this
like a bowl it can look like this like
an upside down right or it can look like
a sad point and in low dimensional space
it's very likely that you're going to
eventually get stuck in a bowl but in
high dimensional space for every single
Dimension if you want to treat it as a
random variable there's like a 50/50
chance that you're going to have at
least one that is not a bowl you're
going to have at least one that's like a
saddle point or something else you can
get through so essentially you get
exponentially decreasing chance of
getting stuck the problem is that while
the neuron Nets and RL are still big
enough for this to happen the space of
strategies itself is not you have a
relatively low dimensional space of
strategies another way to think about
this is just like when you get stuck in
a game it's because at a high level
you're not trying something out right
like you could be pressing all your
buttons but you're not trying something
out at a high level
um yes it's an exploration problem but
the thing is there's no really
principled way to do it so what I would
suggest to you you what I would suggest
to you would be if at all possible with
your problem and you have a fast
simulator which is really where you want
to be just like Define around five
different components that are related to
the reward right like pick five things
that are probably related to agent
performance um have a separate metric
that's not just reward so let's say that
you have like your game has like a
progress metric right through through
the game that's your like your score and
then you just pick five like things in
the game that you think are related to
that and then you have the
hyperparameter tuning algorithm just
tune all the various weights of those so
you don't have to touch the weights of
these different reward components it
gets tuned for you but you still get an
agent that can make use of these reward
signals to optimize something bigger
that's a pretty good strategy at the
moment and uh there's no way in general
to avoid the local Optima you simply
have to have a reward space that can be
shaped such that they don't really exist
as much or that they can be brute forced
around um yeah because getting out of
them requires like higher level
knowledge and [ __ ] it's hard but that's
like a pretty good strategy and that
will generally work pretty well what's
the point of trying to find sample
efficient RL when you show poo is super
sample efficient with carbs well the
thing is like people get really finicky
cuz they like oh well my situation is I
have a robot and I have like 5,000
samples right and it has to learn I
generally think in those situations that
RL is not even the right choice to begin
with RL is really RL shines in high data
regime and there are real problems that
do have high rate data regime you can
bring it down substantially um with good
hyperparameters with maybe different
algorithms and stuff but it's still
going to shine in the high data regime
um so I optimize for this setting first
cuz this is where it's easier to push
experimental progress sample efficiency
is not totally dumb but it does mean it
does like it does mean that if you try
to optimize for ample efficiency during
your research you're not going to get
anywhere those are the best explanations
I can give
um I have I'll tell you a little bit
about this so I have a video coming up
that's like 10 levels of reinforcement
learning where I go through the stack
all the way from hyper parameters down
to environment design and I talk like
for a minute or two on how every single
one of these you know what are the
problems that we're facing now both at a
metal level like the field is facing and
then specifically and I talk about how
puffer is addressing each one of them
but the highle picture of what I'm doing
with puffer is just make tons of super
fast Sims right when you have super fast
Sims you can automatically do good
science via the number of experiments
that you run almost nobody in RL is
doing good science right now which is
why we're stuck because they can't
because everything is too slow and we
build from there and a lot of the stuff
in the middle is just like the
engineering on how you get that stuff
right but it's solved at this point I
know how to do it and it's either done
90% done or like on the back burner
because it's not yet the bottleneck but
I know how to do it there are very very
few things left that I genuinely don't
know how to do I talk about one of them
in there um but genuinely like rl's in a
really really good spot now with puffer
the whole rest of the field is on fire
but like this line of work is doing
great I'm trying to figure out a few
ways to like expand the puffer like the
community and get more people
contributing Sims and stuff as well I
think the live stream is is going to be
fun for that cuz I already have a couple
people doing it eventually we're
probably going to put together bounties
of some sort after puffer gets Revenue
um hopefully we can do something like
that at least uh we'll see
but the other thing is we just need to
get more Hardware like the amount of
Hardware we have right now is not enough
for what I want to do fully with puffer
and the thing is like we can't just grab
slices of time on people's machines uh
that have like 800 setups because the
the hardware we need for all the
existing RL environments is very CPU
heavy actually with the environments I'm
building we're going to be able to use
more standard setups but this is all
there is at the moment
it's just an eight an eight desktop
cluster we need a 50 desktop cluster so
that's going to be one of the relatively
early goals is to get enough Revenue to
fund something like
this since I have a few people listening
quite a few people listening here I'm
going to put I'm going to pose a a cool
problem um I'm going to post something
kind of cool I don't know if I'm going
to put this in the video properly or not
cuz it's like very speculative and it's
kind of wishy-washy
but I I think it's something that folks
could think about and maybe we'll can
actually generate some cool insights so
my original motivation for developing
neural MMO was to have which if you
haven't heard of it's the thing from my
thesis it's a massively multi-agent
environment think like Runescape or
World of Warcraft but built for
reinforcement learning from the ground
up and done doing that for seven years
um so the original motivation for that
was like I saw MMOs as this crazy
complex persistent simulator that if you
were to be able to just train RL agents
in it really fast end to endend they
could learn like all sorts of General
intelligent skills from scratch from the
ground up so you kind of get like
emergent general intelligence at least
some low-level form of emergent general
intelligence and if you could do that I
think you would get the level of result
in AI that you've gotten from language
models but out of RL obviously the field
went completely the opposite direction
and all the money for scaling stuff and
building out all the infrastructure wan
to llms not RL but I think that if
they'd gone the RL way and done that you
would have gotten a similar level of
Competency like it wouldn't be able to
read or it wouldn't be able to process
images but you would like be able to
stick it into any autonomous system and
it would just be able to like go and do
stuff right like any sort of Industry
simulator any sort of like unintuitive
that you don't that doesn't translate
well to language or vision would just be
solved I think that's the level that you
would get out of that so that was the
original goal for neural MMO and I still
think that that's possible but and I
still think an MMO is a good format for
that but I'm thinking I'm still looking
now are there formats of games that also
can do this that are easier to implement
efficiently um and without having to
build out the level of content that
there is in an MMO and there is one
piece of literature well I don't know
literature but there's a good book that
I I Le I listened to recently during one
of my runs um yeah I don't know if you
know the culture series it's like a
well-known SI Sci-Fi series by Ian Banks
it's a very silly series it's very well
written it has a bunch of cool text like
sci-fi stuff in it it's really horny for
some reason I don't know um that was a
little weird but that's beside the point
the thing is there's uh I the the book
is what's what's this specific book
player of games yeah and there's this
concept in here there's this game called
Azad I'm not going to like go through
the whole thing but the concept is that
there is a game that is so complex and
interesting that it can be used to
decide everything in all of society
right so like who who is qualified for
what job play the game right uh is like
who is like qu for what job you know how
should rank be decided like military
structure everything is decided through
this game because it's like a one toone
mapping of all of the type of reasoning
that you have to do to be successful in
the real world um so that type of thing
is what I'm interested in because if you
have an environment that really requires
this level of reasoning but it
self-contained so you can develop this
reasoning just by playing this game
right and it runs really fast that's
like a match made in heaven for
reinforcement learning cuz on one GPU
you could play hundreds and hundreds of
years of this game right just on one GPU
without even having to scale Hardware at
all and the intelligence that could
result from that I think would be
astounding to
folks it's just that we don't have the
simulators and I think that this is
where RL has gotten stuck is just not
having the
simulators because like we have tons and
tons of environments right and it's
gotten to the point where you'll go to
conferences and people will say oh we
don't need more simulators right we have
so so many environments but if you look
at them they're all slow there are
almost no simulators at all that are
fast enough to be reasonably usable
Atari is a few thousand frames per
second until I messed with it a bunch
now I have it up to 30,000 steps per
second train but that's still more than
an order of magnit ude too slow like all
the new Sims that we're building with
puffer are a million steps per second
minimum per CPU
core you can do so so much more with
that so that's what I wanted to leave
you with I that's what I wanted folks to
think about
um I don't know I I don't know if this
is a feasible project right but it's
definitely something I want to look at
as I'm building more Sims for puffer is
like can we build towards that level of
sophistication so I've been going
through a few different board games I've
been going through like a few different
like what are like the most complicated
games ever made what are like really
simple games that are easy to explain
but have really rich Dynamics right
these are things I'm thinking
about so yeah if you have ideas let me
know I hate to end stream when we have
uh this many people but it is
7:41 and I do need to eat dinner
but that's that's sort of my vision for
stuff
right and sometimes the daily work with
this stuff it's usually fun sometimes
it's a bit grindy but that's the
long-term vision of
it
and the main thing in my PhD that killed
it honestly that like didn't get neural
MMO as far as I wanted it was just the
infrastructure it wasn't the algorithms
it wasn't anything it was just not
having infrastructure to make this [ __ ]
fast and like re relative easy to work
with sleepy Joseph creates no good
content at all need sleep yeah I should
get some rest I've been pretty burnt out
lately um here if you haven't already if
you just joined start the puffer it
helps me out a [ __ ] ton and I'll be back
tomorrow I'll be doing some more stuff
uh we're going to hopefully if this
doesn't crash we'll have this where is
it this beam Rider sweep will be
finished we'll have that and we'll be
able to run a new Atari EnV and then the
main thing that you all that you're here
for is we'll have a uh we'll have a
sweep on the new mooba this was the old
sweep the old sweep was really awesome
we'll have a new sweep and hopefully
we'll be able to build out from there
and then we'll see what we do I don't